[Musique]
les quatre nids sont déjà au papa nous a
mis les quatre amis vous diront les
secrets de la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux el pais
mais le plus sérieux
et cela n'avait pas joué aujourd'hui
il suffit de vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]
didot faible oui bonjour d'abord bonjour
bonjour à tous
bonjour sinon bonne nouvelle j'ai un
nouveau jeu ou jour me date qu'est ce
que tu avais appareils bon voila j'ai
appris parce que c'est découvrir un pays
a aujourd'hui vont c'est très facile
parce que c'est un petit peu pour tu
vois pour pour commencer un ballon tu
vois derrière toi là derrière le tableau
il ya une belle fleur
même si la wii la wii bon on va
découvrir un élément deux éléments trois
éléments sur le premier aliment le
contour du pays un an avant le content
de pro tour du pays
bon alors si on ne trouve pas il ya un
deuxième et un deuxième et dimanche que
je vous donnerai weezy le drapeau du
pays
oui et puis si tu ne trouves pas encore
il y aurait un troisième élément
comment dit-on bonjour dans ce pays
voilà un tu sais tout ça je sais tout ça
j'ai fait tout ça voilà alors car on
commence tout de suite tu enlève la
partie gauche de la fleur sylla et tu
vas avoir le contour
bon alors être dieu ça marche les
pilotes oui voilà ça c'est facile ça oui
ça c'est très fouillée aujourd'hui c'est
facile bon maintenant la partie de
droite tu l'enlèves si le dog pound rapp
ort a dit dont je signale quand même une
chose pour le drapeau ceux qui n'ont pas
la couleur
le drapeau est rouge blanc et bleu ce
moment la forme est très caractéristique
ça me paraît assez facile à deviner rien
que le dessin on sait déjà de quel pays
il s'agit c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
ça pour le premier jeu tu combien fait
très bien alors en dessous comment
dit-on bonjour dans ce pays
rodez cause ici je ne me suis pas trompé
on devrait dire à mon avis il dirige
morning et qui espère move et bons trous
good morning
c'est incroyable fait c'est assez facile
il s'agit du royaume uni ou si vous
préférez delà de la grande bretagne
on dit souvent l'angleterre mais c'est
faux hein c'est pas l'angleterre ce
seulement une partie du royaume uni qui
à l'école ce pays de galles irlande du
nord etc s'égailler tu as des as gagné
je suis le plus fort tu es le plus fort
c'est d'ailleurs à de sortir comme saab
on recommence le point com alors on fait
ça va aller au jardin tu verras ya de
jolies fleurs
à cette époque beaucoup d'eau oui oui
c'est vrai c'est un point commun assez
délicat aujourd'hui à celui-ci s'est
affaissé très mal sur la paix oui tu
peux non à paris comme celui là bas si
oui bon déjà rien tron c'est vrai les
fleurs à fabrice j'ai pas le temps de
chômer à tuchan ben voilà c'est tout moi
j'arrive à d'agréables avait entre nous
j'ai peu tard et c'est ça qui m
intéressait d'assister un petit peu à ce
que vous faites
qui es-tu toi et tu cherchais un rapido
j'arrive de loin ah bon oui si tu veux
bien tu restes là on entre nous
travaillons parce que là nous sommes en
train de nous concentrer
qu'est ce que c'est que celui-là rapido
sais pas qui c'est je connais pas il
raconte alors on fait le break aux mains
alors alors rappelons tout de même nos
amis que nous avons en commun c'est une
chose importante
vous allez chacun interprété et quelque
chose ou quelqu'un où il sera et il faut
que vous deveniez ainsi que moi ce qui
les unit quel est le point si l'on prend
comme un sagouin tient pas alors je
commence comme d'habitude alors d'abord
gdl ça ça ne va pas vous surprendre mais
j'ai dl - je lis que les miennes voyez
vous et puis alors j'ai des pâtes six
pattes même g6 passé c'est très
compliqué de marché avec six pattes
ailleurs mais toutes ces âmes toutes ses
factures et allemands sont beaucoup plus
petites que les miennes que celle que
j'ai en réalité ce pire il ya une chose
que je dois avouer qu'on me tend des
pièges on me poursuit on en ions le
vaporise enfin peu voilà ce que je suis
défaite même on me met du bac et
collants je suis pas sûr qu'en
j'aimerais écouter ce que bell bell oui
moi je suis également tout petit enfin
je devrais dire tout petit je ne suis
qu'un petit détail mais très utile dans
la beauté des femmes
oui je suis un peu du mot du sud vrai
aux meubles a beaucoup sur les tables
aux anciens vos grands-mères
on était certainement beaucoup plus
friandes que vous ne l'êtes
je fais encore beaucoup d'effet oui je
ne suis pas grand chose un point c'est
tout
mais quand c'est très bien placé
croyez-moi il se remarque à j'ai une
idée maintenant ça commence et wap ou
smooth urbain moi qu'est ce que tu vois
moi à oui je ne sais pas si tu vas me
croire mais je suis le rêve des
champions 2-2 toutes sortes de tir aux
fléchettes à la carabine à air comprimé
revêt alors ils team poursuivent ils
cherchent et arc
quand ils n'arrivent pas à m'atteindre
salée mais de trois de très mauvaise
humeur ils disent que c'est la malchance
ou non à la tht on pense alors ou alors
quand il arrive un matin dans l'yonne
je suis le plus fort j'ai gagné j'ai mis
dans le mille
et entre nous et ils sont nombreux ceux
qui met dans le mille
alors cuba oui je crois que je commence
à savoir tu m'as parlé des pâtes tu m'as
parlé à les ailes tu pourrais bien être
une vulgaire mouche chez toi bell bell
tu m'as dit un point sur la joue mais je
crois me souvenir que les femmes
utilisés comme moyens d'élégance un
point sur la joue qui ressemblait à un
grain de beauté qui s'appelait une
mouche sabrina et quant à pouss moussu
je pense que tout en tirant au tir sur
une mélange parfois ils pas ça s'appelle
dans les x women on dit également
l'expression ce faire mouche faire
mouche et bah j'ai trouvé à est ce que
vous aviez trouvé aussi oui oui on va je
pense que ça doit être à peu près sa
belle belgique et tracteurs j'ai fait
préparer les petits jeux musique alger
vous fait à tous un petit bisou wisteria
tout abri sera tout à l'heure et en
toile à l'autre
et ben oui bon push moussu cette
anomalie wichita d'où tu es prêt je suis
prêt bon alors tu vas au tableau oui et
je vais découvrir en fait un un mot
voilà que tu vas écrire correctement
cette fois ci j'espère j'espère j'espère
aussi va essayer
bon alors est ce que tu me proposes et
bien c'est en nouant neuf lettres
en fait oui en neuf ans et qui commence
par a ainsi à l'ancien c'est ainsi c'est
petit rets mais pour les lettres qui
manquent
1 2 3 4 5 6
7 et puis alors la fin à la fin un air à
voilà mais est ce que c'est un animal
non non est ce que c'est une plante un
arbre
aa oui à un arbre et marc un arbre eux
le que l'on voit dans nos régions on
renonce aux noms qui ne trouvera pas
dans les forêts françaises non non
voilée dans les pays chauds pour en
trouver en neuf let me un oui alors si
tu veux je te je peux te donner pour
aider la troisième lettre par exemple
vas-y alors la 3e net c'est encore un
c'est encore un c c'est un arbre qu'on
trouve au bord des plages
oui oui on a beaucoup c'est pourquoi si
une forte des gros gros fruit de très
gros fruit d'un dur très dur ça vous
tombe sur la tête ça fait mal tout de
même pour un cocotier vinci bat a trouvé
un cocotier enfin pouces moussu comme en
écriture cocotiers à cocotiers badens et
au co2 tier-1 tous mais il faut verser
au 2t la 2 t2 tête avec rico côté avec
deux t ah oui il ya bien des cocotiers
ça s'écrit comme ça pour lui mais il ya
bien deux t1 cocotte alors ça n'a aucun
rapport iap radicaux cote dans les
cocotiers en vain aux bronzés oh oui oh
c'est hugo cie était un seul t on y eu r
voilà un cocotier en bombant a tu ne
fais pas de progrès
en tout cas en tout cas un thé ni de tes
c'est un arbre qui est rudement ultime
il fournit une boisson rafraîchissante
oui la connaît abbas et le l'époque ne
l'est aussi
attention on en tire aussi des matières
grasses de l'huile du beurre du savon à
va et avec ses fibres ont fait des
ballets des brosses et des tapis a battu
voix j'étais quand même appris quelque
chose
eh ben c'est formidable merci tu sais
seulement si tu es très calés sur les
arbres les plantes et animaux
oui l'orthographe pauvre pouces mot sur
lui l'homme d'affaires de kraft
bon eh ben je crois que maintenant bell
bell est prête j'ai tout genre et c'est
parce que s'entame petit fabrice si je
vais faire vite un baiser mais alors
très vite parce que tu sais signe il
faut que je me concentre à leur écoute
moi bien je rappelle à nos amis comment
les choses se passent tu va nous
raconter quelque chose oui et je
remplacerais par des notes et les mots
qui ne seront pas terminés par toi ou
sont passé mais cette fois que
j'oublierai une si la wii se serait
minutes de musique qu'il faudra que tu
trouves j'en suis preuve alors eux
qu'est ce que je pourrais très coté à
une aventure qui m'est arrivé dimanche
dernier
oui j'étais invité chez des arts à la
compta au bas des amis chez des amis
mais aussitôt de la gare je suis arrivée
juste comment oui c'était c'est
compliqué au stade lagache y regarder la
peau de lille était il était tout juste
dix ans oui me des lits des rivières
guy lux et bien plus voir qui sut petit
thé chaud pendant 11 ans les amis où que
ce soit sur issoire ou que je ne suis
pas bonne c'est moi tu es bon temps et
puis comme il est l'hôte il est doté des
rangs cela ne vous dérange pas si loin
si mais si tu es gentil tu peux rester
tu te tais je parle avec fabrice avant
pourront leur fabrique où ils ont dressé
un tableau
alors donc à midi juste et il s'est mis
à pleuvoir mais alors à pleuvoir on ne
régule et de niagara au sein les chutes
oui c'est à dire l'ancien nombre du dos
une cinquantaine d'autres voilà alors
donc c'était les chutes du niagara
c'est à dire qu'ils tombent et décide de
dissoudre de son tour c'est sa chanson
oui je n'avais pas de parapluie pas
deuxième rideau pas d'attenté de lutte
cela même alors il n'y avait pas un
arbre ça brille pour s'abriter et ce
n'était vraiment pas s'il dit oh tu
salis petite campagne le camp même si
pas épatant si séparés et lucie plongée
d'apporter pour les enfants diktat petit
cadeau 6 à la lettre doat en jeu mais la
lettre d'eau wali et des bonbons tu sais
mallory soumis à fond on ne dit pas s'il
était à chaud qu alors là je sais il
s'agit de chocolat la lettre la wii qui
à longueur pouvait fabrice qui les
aidera c'est vrai ça écoute si tu veux
nous allons essayer de jouer avec ce
petit instrument les notes que nous
avons trouvés ensemble
oui mais si alors voilà qui cause avant
alors ça c'est catherine ce pas
[Musique]
quelle curieuse ça c'est fabuleux on va
c'est pas mal tout de même
oui c'est amusant mais on chante mieux
que sa note olivier qu'est-ce qui lé
long alors
[Musique]
ha ça oui sont déjà pourquoi pas vos
amis les quatre sa fille vous diront je
ferai de la ville d istres et g shock
fait des choses mais comme je n'y pas de
mine noirs libres on a fait attention
les gars ça me compare quand ils sont
réunis les quatre amis sont heureux car
c'est la vie
c'est
combien
et camille ça y est vous avez tu as joué
aujourd'hui et si voir sa vie il suffit
de vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]